[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome
including to our visitors and viewers
from c-span
i am jim kelly director of the gabelli
center of global security analysis at
fordham university
we are proud to be co-sponsoring this
webinar on lincolnomics with our
partners
the museum of american finance and the
cfa society of new york
this event is part of our centennial
series celebrating 100 years of
purpose-driven business education at
fordham
it is particularly timely since we are
currently offering a course in financial
history
at fordham in conjunction with the
museum of american finance
during the presentation please enter
your questions by typing them in the q a
section near the bottom of your zoom
screen
we will be addressing as many questions
as possible after the presentation
lastly
as a participant in today's webinar
you will be entered into a raffle to win
a free ebook of lincolnomics
winners will be notified at the end of
the week
now i would like to turn it over to
david cowan president of the museum of
american finance who will introduce our
speaker
thank you thanks jim and it's uh always
great to be back with you the cabelli
school our friends at the cfa
and this is the third time i've had the
pleasure to introduce john
and the first time i introduced him he
had written 10 books which i thought was
pretty impressive well the second time
he was up to 16 and now we're up to 19
books so congratulations on that uh john
and this book is particularly timely
because in part of it he's discussing
about infrastructure as we know congress
is currently debating an infrastructure
bill and john ponders several times
throughout the book quote unquote
what would lincoln do
now john's prolific writing
also includes over one thousand columns
blogs and articles in places like the
new york times the wall street journal
reuters forbes and bloomberg but most
importantly of course our own magazine a
financial history in an article based on
the book will be out in the spring issue
sometime next month
john has appeared on many media outlets
from nbc to npr
cnn to cnbc
msnbc to pbs
now he's a native of illinois and during
his childhood he visited many lincoln
tourist destinations and he continued on
doing that as an adult around the
country visiting various tourist sites
therefore uh when you read the book
there's several great appendices and one
of them is his reviews that i don't want
you to miss of the various lincoln
tourist destinations
now john it has been a very uh difficult
12 or 13 months for this country so
please tell us
what would lincoln do
thank you so much david for that
generous intro it's it's always a
pleasure to speak at the museum of
american finance and thanks so much to
our
our great sponsors from the gability
school of business center for global
security analysis cfa society of new
york
and
all of you for attending this this uh
zoom session on on what i hope will be
uh a revealing a new look at abraham
lincoln in infrastructure
uh
the story starts
in 1828
a young man
is taking a flat boat
transporting goods hogs
agricultural produce
from southern indiana on the ohio river
down the mississippi to new orleans
and the way he discovers
two things
he sees that
people who are enslaved do not have the
same
economic opportunity
to advance their own station
and it's a moral evil
he also sees the importance
of transporting goods to markets and
having access to those markets no matter
where you live
so if you're a rural farmer wherever in
the country uh you don't have to go
through this labyrinth
of what was then the interstate system
on
the nation's
large rivers to get there
this young man was abraham lincoln he
took another trip out of springfield
illinois
1828 is a really important year though
because that's when the erie canal
opened
that gave
new york city which became of course one
of the greatest ports in the world
access to
the markets west
uh into the great lakes
at the time chicago wasn't even a city
it was a swampy trading uh post um
very inaccessible because the only way
of getting down uh to the mississippi
river was was through a ugly portage
called mud lake
uh which even in 18 or 1673
uh two explorers julian and marquette
father marquette
um
said hey there should be a canal here
because if you connect the chicago river
to lake michigan the great lakes the
erie canal new york city
you can get to new orleans because then
you can get to the illinois river and
then the mississippi
and onto the crescent city
so that was one of the first impressions
that
young abraham lincoln had
as the nation was growing in 1830s
it was really a
a time that we don't really study a
whole lot
because we mostly skipped from the
revolution to the civil war
there was a lot of history in between
one of the reasons i wrote the book
because i wanted to know how did our
country develop what did we need to do
to get to where we are today
and eventually what do we need to do to
get
deeper into the future into the more
equitable present
so what was really important about that
that one trip
it was a very huckleberry fin like trip
for lincoln it changed his world view it
changed his thinking it changed the way
he said things in public
one of his first
really campaign planks in the 1830s when
he ran for the general assembly he's in
springfield illinois now still a young
man in his 20s
failed at it running two stores uh tried
surveying
uh was splitting wood was doing anything
to make ends meet he had some debts
uh a partner in a store left them high
and dry he had to pay off those debts
and he did all this
uh while being very curious about the
world and about markets and economics
and and things that would transform not
only his life but the life of all
rural americans and even people in
cities
so he
he proposed something very interesting
the first thing he said was that we need
to build a canal
from springfield all the way to the
illinois river which would have
facilitated a great newport and a great
new
access to the markets in new orleans and
further south and also
to create a canal that would later be
called the illinois michigan canal which
would connect chicago to the illinois
river it's only about 96 miles
and
as a third thing which actually was
pooh-poohed at the time because
everybody thought it was going to be way
too expensive was a major railroad line
to connect the whole state to the rest
of the eastern markets at the time and
that railroad was going to be called the
illinois central so he worked with a
fellow named steven douglas his great
rival throughout life
in politics to get this done the
illinois legislature passed this massive
infrastructure plan and then promptly
went bust
it was under capitalized uh the canal uh
had to take some time off because they
didn't have the money to hire irish
laborers to
to get paid almost nothing to dig it by
hand
but that was something that that had to
be done in order to open up chicago the
great lakes uh and the rest of illinois
to uh global markets
lincoln saw this early he campaigned for
it and he was fairly successful in
convincing people
that this should be done
um he wanted to put rural farmers in
anybody who wasn't living near a big
city or a salt water port on equal
floating with everybody else how do you
do this well you create transportation
routes you build the infrastructure to
get people there
so lincoln was fairly successful as a
young assemblyman
but what was more important is that he
introduced this this concept based on
henry clay's american system that if you
build infrastructure
it would create economic progress
this was fundamental to the
wig view of of the world in the united
states uh henry clay was a whig uh
abraham lincoln was an early wig and
they were very much into building
infrastructure and tariffs to pay for
them
internal tariffs uh and and they did
this uh at a time when
they called it the era of good feelings
i'm not i'm never quite sure why they
call it that but
the biggest thing at that time was to
build canals all over the country uh to
connect these major river systems which
were our interstates then
uh of course uh railroads took off in
the following uh decade in the 1840s and
then you know what became uh
this huge uh interstate system really
took off because the canals exceeded the
growth now what had happened when
lincoln first proposed his little canal
uh called the sangamon canal out of
springfield was that
he knew that
any place where the canal was at a
conjunction with another river system in
this case the illinois
then a lot of commerce and development
would take off
and this is very little known but he
actually was an urban planner he planned
a town
at the intersection of this canal
called huron as in lake huron
it of course was never built
um i saw the plans in doing the research
and something i had never known about
lincoln uh and then of course he moved
on to become a lawyer to make a little
bit more money uh and he and he was a
very successful lawyer and he kind of
dropped out of politics until 1854.
now in the interim
america is growing at a rapid pace
the iron i m canal illinois michigan
canal opens up 1848.
uh what happens it creates this major
city on the other end of it chicago
chicago remember it was a
a dumpy little swampy area uh
right on lake michigan
uh and what it becomes is this major
shipping port it becomes
the busiest port in the country when the
canal is finished
for at least another decade and by 1900
the population growth is so explosive
that it becomes the fastest growing city
in the world
at the turn of the century and that was
facilitated by this idea that lincoln
champion along with stephen douglas
even more importantly the illinois
central railroad which really was built
to supplement what was going up and down
the canals
becomes the longest railroad in the
world by 1850
eventually it goes from the northwest
tip of illinois
all the way to new orleans but not until
after the civil war and because it comes
a major transit route for troop and
materiel during the civil war so keep
those two things in mind these are two
immense developments in the history of
the country uh the midwest uh you know
links eastern markets to western markets
to the southern port it's globalization
um in a very small sense but in a very
uh growing sense now what happens
when the civil war comes along well we
know what lincoln says uh we we know
about the house divided speech we know
about his lincoln douglas debates but i
i started going into some of the
material and and found something very
interesting that he said
literally in the first debate with
stephen douglas ottawa illinois 1858 he
was running for senator at that time
against douglas
douglas had controlled the illinois
democratic party
and at that time
senators were not directly elected they
were directly
elected by state legislatures so
he became
the senator so what happened was that
lincoln
in
talking about slavery made another
argument
and this was during the first debate he
said you know every man has a right to
earn his own bread
and to be on i'm paraphrasing to be on
an equal footing with everyone
so this this is lincoln's view of
economic progress that you have a right
to
um offer your labor for for pay
that you have the opportunity
to ascend the economic ladder and he
used those words economic ladder how do
you move up how do you avoid being this
back woodsman all your life
doomed to hard scrabble farming how do
you do that
well this is part of the american system
the american ethos that we've kind of
grown up to learn
um in in our history but there's more to
it than that here's here's something
even more exciting so
this is another side plot in the whole
lincoln story that really during his
sort of um
i wouldn't call it exile but is his
estrangement from politics which which
lasts roughly from uh the time he leaves
the general assembly to roughly
1854 when uh douglas passes the kansas
nebraska act uh allowing for expansion
of slavery in the western territories um
lincoln comes to this realization that
you know what what is really important
here other than
you know ending the evil of slavery is
that we still need to pay attention to
infrastructure 1847 his only term in the
house of representatives he uh he
actually gives a very long speech one of
his longest speech ever
on infrastructure why is it important to
have ports and canals and railroads what
does it mean to the the health and the
future of the nation well lincoln
thought it was essential and in fact he
was he was disparaging uh president polk
at the time for fighting the mexican war
in neglecting this this huge national
issue and keep in mind that up until
lincoln's era
that many of the founding fathers many
southerners thought that federal funding
of infrastructure was unconstitutional
james monroe himself said in an annual
message
even before the canal er what i you know
i like the idea you know we should be
building roads and canals and things
like that but it's not in the
constitution
so that was used as an argument against
federal funding of infrastructure for
uh decades decades before the civil war
so
lincoln selected
1860 um there's the secession of the
southern states lincoln has to go into
washington uh by secret route because
there's assassination
plot attempts he gets there
and the civil war starts
now
in prosecuting the civil war you know
lincoln's record is very well known
but what he had embedded in some of his
very basic messages were very
foundational ideas on
raising all boats through economic
progress well what did he favor well
first of all the transcontinental
railroad it became a very popular idea
in 1840s john c fremont who ran for
president against buchanan
uh campaigned on that
he was one of the first republicans
republican party doesn't come along
until the mid
19th century 1850s
and the new republican party of course
is is against slavery and for the
transcontinental railroad and lincoln
having represented
the uh illinois central as a as as a
lawyer
knew the importance of it so he favors
that mentions that in one of his annual
messages which were then the state of
the union speeches um and mentions a
whole bunch of other things he
is the first president
to
um do a telegraph message
transcontinental he gets a message from
san francisco and uh he loves the
telegraph as we know from history in the
civil war he spends a lot of time in
telegraph room uh getting dispatches
from the various battles
first years of the war went very badly
for the union and of course um you know
lincoln is shuffling generals he's he's
trying to get his troops where they need
to be um and most of them are
the better generals it turns out are the
uh railroad engineers who became
generals uh and they
later become active in the
transcontinental railroad building so
and here's what's even remarkable at the
height of the civil war
this god awful bloodshed 700 000 people
lose their lives um the majority of them
lose them
lose their lives in in in the camps
uh to various diseases typhus and
diphtheria and pneumonia and of course
there's no cure form and when they have
no idea what's going on because
you know the germ theory of disease
doesn't come along until like 20 30
years later
so lincoln is an early advocate of
medical research
he establishes a pathology institute
um and i found the papers where he talks
about using disinfectants
in in some of the union camps to and he
doesn't even know about germs he just
hears about it i saw a letter in the
archives where he says hi this this
looks like a really good idea so he's
he's our innovator in chief he wants to
do new things he wants to see
new ways of of communicating of
transporting goods of of getting us to
where we need to be
and one of the the biggest
sort of fell swoops uh that he signs in
the law are three very fundamental uh
laws the homestead act uh which allows
people basically free land out west uh
the moral act which establishes
land-grant colleges and of course uh the
pacific railway acts two two laws
actually which finance and give the land
for the transcontinental railroad
the following year that was 1862 the
following year he also passes the
national banking act
and this is for the first time
established as the greenback that green
dollar uh that is our national currency
um and establishes uh also an income tax
to pay for the war and
during the war the union economy
actually uh the gdp increases um it was
a very small tax three percent they have
made over eight hundred dollars to pay
it it's a flat tax uh but it was the
first income tax repealed in 1873 i
believe uh then it comes back in 1913
but it was the first way of the national
government
financing its expenses on on that level
so that was a very important development
so all this happens during the civil war
of course there are the the horrible
battles gettysburg vicksburg also in
1863
um and then the war is over uh lincoln
loses his life
um
1865 he's assassinated for its either um
but his legacy lives on
and here's here's the most amazing part
of the story is that lincoln's view of
economic progress that is building
infrastructure raising all boats
really comes out of another part of his
his psyche
in 1847 he had actually invented a boat
it was a boat that was designed to lift
up not a very big boat but it would lift
it up if it was in shallow waters
and he patented before he left
washington in 1848 and traveled on the
illinois michigan canal so lincoln
is the only president
who is a patented inventor
so he always had this in the back of his
mind being the innovator in chief it was
like how do we do things better how do
we use technology how do we really uh do
the things that we're really good at um
to make this a better country for
everyone
so that was those are the the principal
things i discovered but again the legacy
lives on he inspired a whole new
generation of progression
progressive politicians uh and thinkers
frank lloyd wright jane adams social
reforms uh the lincoln highway which was
the first national east west route goes
from times square all the way to san
francisco
was named after him and inspired by him
in fact i was born just off the lincoln
highway uh the hospital where i was born
no longer exists but
it was called the crossroads of america
and of course there's there's lincoln
all over my state uh in
he's on our license plate
so we have all this inspiration and then
it goes even further the roads in this
country were
really terrible going from from one part
of the country to another
especially from the midwest to the west
in 1919 a young colonel named dwight
eisenhower takes the convoy to explore
the state of of the roads along the
lincoln highway um from
uh one coast to the other and and it
comes to the the real uh
undeniable conclusion that they're just
awful some of the routes falling um the
the road out of iowa were just kind of
ruts they were like pioneer trails and
they go through the mountains and the
deserts
and and from that time on even into the
new dealer people were saying how do we
how do we pay for this how do we do this
well the first idea was the lincoln
highway so that was 1910 1913
uh in the first concept of financing it
was that it should be privately financed
so an entrepreneur
who was really the heir to the packard
fortune says you know we can raise some
money to do this
henry ford says to him look
um you're not going to do this with
private money and i'm not not going to
contribute you're going to need federal
funding to do this
so uh they don't raise enough money they
they get some subscribers including
um you know
woodrow wilson again i think he gave
five bucks or something and and it's
just terribly under financed and it
doesn't really happen until eisenhower
becomes president 1956 interstate
highway act
and creates the the largest network of
highways on the planet 40 000 miles plus
um i tried inflation adjusted
for today's dollars it would have been
at least 600 billion dollar project
now we face uh at least six trillion
dollars in repairs of course you know
there's proposal for the two trillion
dollar dollar american jobs plan uh by
president biden and we're looking at
that now
so
as with a lot of my stories and i've
this is like my fifth book on
infrastructure history finance uh
telling stories about
uh the people behind these ideas
uh and and the principle here is is very
powerful
that you do need to make these
investments uh this is how we we link
our our cities our towns our farm fields
um from coast to coast um and you know
there's there's a lot of things we need
to do
um and i'd be happy to take questions on
this but i'll leave you with this one
thing
um
that what we are very good at
that lincoln
really personified
was this idea that innovation
uh would not only lift our our economic
station you know through
entrepreneurship invention discovery
new technologies
but also lift our spirit
that that this is this is aspirational
we still truly believe
that this new invention or this new
stock coming on the market or this new
idea is going to change the world and
that's what i think makes us americans
and that's
part of the path forward i think and one
of the reasons i wrote this book and i
have to tell you uh one last sort of
anecdote about it is that i wrote it
backwards i started out with the covet
era
in the pandemic we're in now and i lost
two friends i know lots of people
who lost friends and in my condolences
if you knew somebody who who perished in
this this ugly thing
um
but but it revealed something about us
that we we do need to create a better
infrastructure a better social
infrastructure better educational
infrastructure
a health infrastructure as well as the
physical infrastructure better roads
bridges tunnels railroads um you know
all these things that come under that
that huge category of infrastructure and
i i can't say enough that that building
is what we do
and and it and it also builds our spirit
and our confidence in and gives us
something to to hope for
uh it's aspirational and with that i i
would love to take your questions and um
i there's there's there's a whole bunch
of stories in the book um and
it's it was it was a pure joy to write
living in the land of lincoln and uh
people asked me well how long did it
take you to write this so like well
all my life but
this is an ongoing story and i hope all
of you will contribute uh to this this
effort to realize what we need to do
and we're back to jim i think
yeah well thank you very much john just
to start it off um
and let me before i even even ask a
question let me encourage everyone to
please uh enter your own questions in
the q a box and we'll keep going on that
basis um
but the tariff was the main source of
income back then do you think lincoln
would be in favor of higher tariffs
today say on china
well i think that the whole tariff
formula proved to be not enough to do
what we needed to do in terms of
infrastructure and there was this was
the whole argument during the the 19th
century
tariffs were used to fund um some
infrastructure but it wasn't enough
um is it a good way to finance these
things um you know i'll leave that to
the historians and the financial
analysts i think that you know what we
do need is the broad-based sustainable
way of financing this whether it's
public private or through bonds or
through
carbon tax there's there's so many
proposals on the table but we need to
get that discussion going because
obviously if you
you know look at the nation as is our
house
so if you don't invest in your house
um you know the
you'll need to paint it you'll need to
replace the heating the air conditioning
all these things just wear out uh and if
you don't do that then then you're
looking at problems so you know the
house is
is our nation and it does need to be
fixed and upgraded and put in new
technology we need to address climate
change
all these things so we we do need and
that is that is the current argument how
do we do this how do we finance it
john uh you mentioned uh in the book and
you just mentioned also innovator in
chief and one of the things i'll relate
to that you did mention the patent i'm
wondering if you could expand upon that
because he's as you say in the book the
only president and then secondly a
lesser known story uh which you bring
out is a dual challenge believe it or
not that lincoln had um and just a
little bit about that for the audience
because again most people aren't aware
of those two facts
well they're two really good stories and
they both happen
at different times but the the inventor
story was that
you know for lincoln to get to
washington he had to take this god-awful
route uh you know through the great
lakes
through the erie canal down the hudson
river and sometimes he took the overland
routes
and often when he was on a boat in the
great lakes they would get stuck
on shoals and then you know they'd have
to you know pry the boat loose with
physical labor and so he he came up with
this id literally designed it on the
ship
where he had these poles i wish he had a
picture of it um would lift it up and he
had these inflatable um
buoys that would float the boat up
higher and it was really clever
invention he made a model of it he had a
friend constructed it's it's now in the
smithsonian it was a beautiful looking
craft um not built as far as i know um
it you know be on the model stage and
and nobody using besides in the railroad
era there was
probably not that much need for it uh
the the dual challenge was um
lincoln had some
some issues with depression
and he had several courtships um one of
his sweethearts died that was ann
rutledge uh in springfield
madeleine what in love with her she dies
he's bereft uh and he gets very
depressed and there was an uh mary owens
uh before he meets um mary todd uh who
is who's very sprightly
intelligent politically savvy you know
new henry clay uh grew up with with you
know that whole uh culture in louisville
kentucky a fellow kentuckian
and and
you know lincoln was very awkward uh
socially for some reason
unless he was giving a speech
and um things didn't go well at first
with mary uh and then
then they broke it off and he was
horribly depressed and his friend joshua
speed took away his razor he wouldn't
come out of his bed and and he was just
terrible and then somebody insulted him
and there was there was a duel challenge
and and fortunately you know
19th century duels were kind of complex
affairs you could you could apologize or
somebody could broker a piece and well
that's what happened so he didn't fight
the duel and that was a good thing if we
lost lincoln it would
i can't imagine what this country would
be like
good question thank you david okay john
here's an interesting one if you could
pick one thing to spend infrastructure
money on today what would it be
um that's an easy one for me uh it would
be healthcare uh because uh one of the
things they discovered in sort of
writing the book backwards
is that there are massive inequities in
terms of health care coverage between
communities of color
and in the rest of the country it's it's
very unevenly divided i mean i live in a
county north of the city where we we
have a plethora of of really good
hospitals but if you go the south side
of chicago it's not the case they're
struggling to keep hospitals open
so i i would spend the money and say
look how do we have a broad-based plan
so that everybody gets you know
really decent basic health care um
i don't know if that's a national health
care system or if it's medicare for all
but we need to come up with something i
mean the kovid price crisis really
exposed
a lot of these inequities and and it was
just
it was horrible because some people
didn't have access to health care or
they they didn't go into the hospital
because they they were afraid they
couldn't pay for it so this this is part
of my social infrastructure argument
that i think lincoln would have embraced
uh because um and i even go as far as
invoking the 14th amendment which was
inspired by him the equal treatment
clause saying hey you know at the very
least in this country we should treat
everybody
fairly and equally
of course they haven't been but i think
that's something we need to talk about
when we talk about infrastructure
very
good donna leo schmidt would like to
know would lincoln be in favor of a line
item veto in order to keep pork belly
financing out of infrastructure bills
you know i don't think that he would
have um
looked at that specifically because he
was kind of a big picture thinker
so he you know transcontinental railroad
how big of a project was that um and of
course you know when you look at history
as like well god it's about spawn the
robber baron era and on all this waste
and displacement of native americans and
in in murdering them and putting them on
reservations i mean there are a lot of
bad things that happen because of
expansionist uh economic policies no
doubt about it
but how can you see that and i don't
know what he would have thought to be
honest with you about illini of vedam
the question during his time wasn't
necessarily government waste it was
government not spending enough money on
on the things that didn't matter to the
the most the greatest number of people
so
that's a tough one and and i'm i'm gonna
really uh pass on that but um
i i think he would have looked at it
eventually he was very open-minded to
new ideas
okay john
abraham lincoln and frederick douglass
knew each other well
please tell us about their rapport and
how their relationship impacted
lincoln's values and policies
well uh in modern parlance i think they
would have been frenemies
so um
lincoln was the first president i i
could tell who welcomed uh douglas into
the white house uh douglas was of course
a very accomplished thinker speaker
abolitionist i mean uh he wrote two
autobiographies and you read him he's
he's he's amazing he just opens up the
whole issue of of slavery and economic
equality and what we need to do i mean
he was there there's probably no better
person
uh if you want to understand where we're
at today than to read frederick douglass
there's also a really good biography on
out on him right now
um so
but you know duncas was very critical
of lincoln in the early years even
though they talked on
what we would consider to be a fairly
regular basis and he was in the white
house and and lincoln welcomed him in um
douglas didn't think that lincoln was
doing enough
to end slavery of course emancipation
proclamation did not end slavery in in
totality um and it was an incomplete uh
declaration uh that mostly freed uh
slaves to fight uh for the union side uh
so that's one interpretation in in
all the pieces that needed to follow um
equal education
uh in in funding infrastructure for
every community
that would come later but actually
douglas lived in the 1880s uh and and
pretty much was
uh
advocating for uh equal rights uh he was
at the 1893 world's colombian exposition
uh in chicago as a matter of fact um and
and i think that um
in the end he agreed that lincoln had
done more than any other president
to advance the issue of equality and
ending slavery and i don't think too
many historians are going to disagree
with that of course
inspired the 13th 14th and 15th
amendments
and of course the the great civil rights
legislation of the 60s but i i think
both men would agree that there's more
work that needs to be done
there's a different kind of question for
you how would lincoln convince folks
that broadband is the new canal system
well i i don't think he would hesitate
in doing it david and and this is why
so
when he received and sent the first
telegraph message by a president
so morse had been peddling his
um
his invention since the 1840s
and he was he was he was really
struggling to convince people like hey
you know this is uh global
communications folks this this is
you know instead of like pony express
and putting something on a packet boat
and uh you know the the slow route
um you know you you're sending messages
at the speed of light
and this this was a quantum leap and and
lincoln just loved the idea um and and
there's all these accounts of him being
in the telegraph room in the white house
uh receiving and sending messages and it
was
something i think he would have
wholeheartedly embraced broadpen
everywhere so we can all be hooked up to
the same network the same system
travel you know globally the speed of
light i think he would have loved the
idea
okay we've got some good questions
coming in keep them coming please
um
here's what i'm wondering what lincoln's
actions on education were and if any of
his ideas would apply today to help fix
inequality
well here's a great back story so the
moral act uh which he signed in
1862
establishes land-grant colleges you know
the state universities that we know
today
the first iteration just really set
aside
um you know 30 000 acres per state state
could do anything they wanted they could
sell it they could farm it you know they
could produce income from it and that
was the concept of the land grant it
wasn't a direct subsidy as as we know
today
um and it was the principal means in the
19th century for
for doing something big because the
federal government really didn't have
the income for one thing and of course
there was the states rights argument
that states should be doing this first
well you know states just didn't have
the ability to raise the capital um and
you know a lot of the investment that
went into these things was foreign
investment especially
transcontinental railroad like the
illinois central
uh so education lincoln
i discovered
was
so focused on education because of his
own shortfalls in that area he only had
about a year of formal education and the
rest was was self-learned he he learned
the law on his own and he he became a
lawyer and he and he studied and he was
a great reader
uh of all sorts of history he also read
euclid so he was into math um in in in
all sorts of subjects that i never knew
that he read
so he would have embraced the idea of
expanding
um the educational system and the moral
act was just one of many there were
several other sort of extensions of that
that went into the 20th century that
established
universities historically black colleges
came out of that um
it
native american colleges came out of
that in in subsequent iterations which i
think he would have loved but the real
backstory is even more interesting than
that uh justin moral the vermont senator
who had his name attached to it
originally proposed
land grant universities
uh really inspired by a neo idea by
jonathan baldwin turner who knew lincoln
as a young man and it proposed
this whole idea of the land grant what
he called the industrial university
which would be teaching uh two basic
things agriculture and what they call
the mechanical arts uh which became
engineering so he had this idea for
decades and then pretty much passed it
on to um tomorrow who who actually tried
to get it passed in 1858 buchanan vetoed
it and then it became law under lincoln
but lincoln was very well aware of
turner
um he
had him as a visitor at the white house
during the civil war
turner was a very famous abolitionist
ironically in the same town where
stephen douglas got to start
jacksonville illinois so he he's kind of
the father of the moral act um and and
what we call you know the state college
systems engineering schools things like
that
we have a what if question for you what
do you believe president lincoln would
have achieved if he had been able to
serve out his second term
well i i think that's one of our most
essential questions to ask today
the the the low-hanging fruit for me is
that he would have completed
reconstruction and had he lived even
longer he wouldn't have abandoned it in
1870s um and and then that course led to
the horrible jim crow era and lynchings
and some some really um
really awful times in our history
so lincoln would have would have
followed through he would have witnessed
the passage
the 13th 14th the 15th amendment and he
would have taken it a step further he
would have ensured that there was
political equality um complete voting
rights um and you know
we generally credit him for being the
inspiration of of the great society
programs uh the civil rights laws of the
60s so i i think
he would have been
able to see that through and add to it
um
he he was definitely the uh the the you
know the soul of all those laws
john
i'm curious
how would you um
explain or interpret the transition
between the canal system and the the
rail system how long did that take and
what were the um
you know the stages of development
well that's that's a really fascinating
question uh jim and and
it it didn't really take long in terms
of of history because what needed to
happen for railroads to take off is they
had to mass produce rail they had to um
cut a lot of trees to to build the ties
they had to create the technology to
uh extend rail over long distances
and with that came improvements in the
steam engine
braking systems
a lot of this business was centered in
chicago and one of the kind of ironic
facts of history is that
uh the pullman car company was was one
of chicago's biggest industries um you
know from its inception and they
literally had to build all these cars
out of wood uh lincoln traveled in
pullman cars and his son robert lincoln
uh who became a lawyer um was president
of the pullman company uh for a while
and um he you know there was a horrible
pullman strike there
so uh that was that was an important
part so
with every one of these stories there's
incremental advances in history you know
how do you build a better rail that's
going to be durable in all conditions
how do you make better steel how do you
make better iron you know a lot of this
happened you know in the steel mills of
chicago pittsburgh cleveland uh where he
had all these these things that really
contributed to the advancement of one
technology so so we go from the canal er
which is basically 1830s 1840s rail
starts to take off because they can mass
produce
you know railroad cars and engines
and ties and and you know the spikes uh
when the golden spike is is driven into
the completion of the transcontinental
railroad in 1869
uh a lot of interesting things happened
they they had to reinvent how they built
bridges before the iron era most bridges
were made out of wood in fact here's
here's one great story that i had in the
book lincoln was defending a company
that had built a bridge across the
mississippi river in rock island
illinois uh and the railroad of course
needed to get across the river um and at
that time this is straight right at the
end of the steamboat era so this all the
whole steamboat industry thought they
owned the river they had a right to this
river and in no upstart technology like
railroads gonna cross their river right
so there was this is an incident where
the steamboat either crashed or lost
control and and hit this bridge and
since the river was uh the bridge was
made of wood it burned to the ground uh
so the steamboat owner who had
underinsured his ship
sues the bridge company and they bring
on lincoln as an attorney to represent
the bridge company and he makes this
really interesting argument he doesn't
win that case it ends in a hung jury but
eventually it's won and he makes this
this really compelling statement is like
look this is just not a bridge this is
not an impediment to commerce or trade
or anything
this is a public amenity this links you
know chicago the east the rest of the
country across the mississippi and we
didn't
build more of these things and they
belong to the public they don't you know
they're not stopping commerce they're
not stopping people from discovering
land in the west we need it so that was
a real important case it was called the
effie afton case i wrote a whole chapter
on and i was just fascinated about how
lincoln constructed this argument about
the the public good of infrastructure
john h.r 40 is in front of uh or
possibly in front of congress dealing
with reparations for descendants of
slaves what would lincoln think about it
i think he would think about it
thoughtfully and and i
it's a complex subject
and and i really
think that we need to address the
inequities uh in in all of our systems
uh in education and health care
in in the fact that you know there's
there's an environmental justice issue
that a lot of uh toxic you know
plants and refineries have build built
in communities of color
i mean there's there's a whole raft of
things that i think lincoln would have
fundamentally addressed
because it really spoke to his sense of
of fairness
and the in the the idea that equality is
truly based on
your your ability to take advantage of
an opportunity and if somehow you're
held back
uh for whatever reason um it should be
addressed so i i think he would have
discussed it i think he would have um
talked to frederick douglass about it uh
had he lived he would have talked to
booker t washington and all the people
who were
um
talking about it today i i even
think that he would have taken a hard
look at you know how do we how do we do
this
[Music]
one finance uh specific question john
how how were the canals financed
publicly or privately and also the
railroads i know there was a lot of
speculation in the stock markets but can
you explain how that whole thing
this whole process was was financed
well
this this is one of the interesting
stories of american finance
is that when for example
the state of illinois
financed uh the illinois michigan canal
it it floated some bonds which were
horribly
uh
inadequate to to to pay for this so what
they did is they they said okay we're
gonna award contracts to uh private
contractors who can hire their own
workers
um to build small sections of the canal
which you're thinking you know in
management theory probably not a good
idea and you know today's age you know
you hire one contractor
uh you you know you you put the contract
out for bid you know the the best bidder
gets the job well anyway they they would
um
they'd send notices out to ireland and
and other countries in europe say hey
you wanna
they promised these poor irish guys is
like hey you want to be a navigator on a
canal and that's what they called them
navigators and they were digging the the
thing by hand
so at first it was it was this this
really under capitalized proc uh prog
project and then they got foreign
financing so a lot of foreign money came
into
uh building these canals and then into
the railroads
and of course the land grant system was
that
well basically you get the land
and uh you find the money to build it
there was some money raised for the
trans-continental railroad again it was
mostly bonds
but there there was a lot of foreign
investment
uh john with 19 books you know now to
your credit what's number 20 going to be
about
well david i'm hoping it's going to be
about
bringing the environment to every
neighborhood in the country um climate
change is of course our existential
threat
and it's sort of uh what i call a
reverse walden where we'll look well how
do we enjoy
nature
in suburbia in the middle of the city
and and what does that mean um
how do we produce our own energy how do
we clean our air and our water and stuff
like that and how do you localize it you
know one of the things that i i really
discussed in the book is that you know
climate change is affects everything and
it certainly affects our way of looking
at infrastructure we have to build
bridges higher we have to redesign our
water systems i mean everything
um so
this this book would look at well how do
we like kind of
shrink this question down break it down
a little bit it's like what does it mean
for my neighborhood so
that hopefully
will be my next book and i would call it
the natural neighborhood
okay
i have
one
one or two more i guess um
do you see
would lincoln have embraced the concept
of public-private partnerships
i'm just thinking of the pandemic for
example with the cooperation of the
federal government and the
pharmaceutical companies would is there
any analogies back in that era of
public-private partnerships
i think so so uh you know when a lot of
these projects were done
um
what really
provide an undergirding of of the
financial structure of them was the fact
that they they were able to solicit
eastern and european investors so
you know the the most the federal
government could do because it owned
most of the land
that had been appropriated from native
americans
and they could say look
we'll give you the land
um you know maybe the states can help a
little bit with floating some bonds but
it won't be enough it's it's never
enough
uh and you're going to have to find the
rest of the money to do this and that
was certainly the story with
you know all the railroads you know
all the railroads that came after the
transcontinental railroad um you know
the local systems um and and there was a
one side story this uh
originally a journalist named henry
villard
uh had had started out his career
covering the civil war
uh created the first newspaper syndicate
and became a friend of lincoln
but
he eventually got so much information on
some of these railroad projects going
out west that he became an investor in a
financier there's there the famous
velard house in in manhattan that was
henry villard um of course he lost a lot
of that fortuna railroad stocks crashed
uh they went up and down um but he
eventually uh financed thomas edison
um so that that's another great story
but he brought in he would go back to
german investors because he was
originally from germany and say hey look
you know this railroad you're financing
in kansas city uh you know you might
want to take another look at the
the paper and the statements and you
know i i can help you with this and
he he made huge brokerage fees and then
he got stock and then he became filthy
rich but
the velard house is still there and and
his history is is just
probably as interesting as as anybody
else from that gilded era
so john for our final question before we
close you've been to so many lincoln
tourist destinations
which is your favor
oh gosh david uh
that's a tough one it's like picking
your favorite child that's not fair come
on
um
you know
the the thing that that really strikes
me and and this is not something
that most people even
associate with lincoln is a place called
lincoln landing it's in lockport
illinois and lincoln actually it's one
of those things where lincoln came
through there
um you know after his only term in
congress and i and and that would that's
really what spurred my my imagination
and thinking i was like
how did lincoln see the future of the
country you know he helped get this
canal built it created a great city in
all the towns along it you know and you
think of all the towns along the erie
canal in new york city in new orleans
and and all the things that happened
after it but he had this vision and and
sometimes places have this power to
to to really instill this vision and you
know
you know you try to get into lincoln's
head and you know all of us have tried
and we don't
we don't completely understand him we
never will but it's important to to see
what he saw and to feel maybe what he
felt
and to know with it to aspire to a
better country
was was was still a worthy goal and a
moral principle that that we can't
abandon
well john on behalf of the gabelli
school the cfa it is wonderful to again
have you back uh to our audience thank
you for tuning in we've got great
programs again coming up with several
wall street legends including uh peter
cohn
and dr henry kaufman so on behalf of all
of us again john thank you very much
thank you it's been such a pleasure and
i just hope and pray that
we'll get back to a healthy healing
country again and i'll i'll be back in
new york city with my friends and i miss
you all terribly but i wish everybody
the best
[Music]